hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast innovative quantitative
imaging techniques and their utility an
advancing neurobiology research
I am Marjorie Torres of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are excited to bring you this
educational webcast presented by lab
roots and sponsored by Ditka part of
thermo Fisher Scientific
typical media supplement cells and cell
culture reagents are designed to deliver
reproducibility and performance for
results we can count on every day for
more information please visit
www.un.org/webcast
i typing them in the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as you can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or hear
in this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right hand of
your presentation window or submit your
problem to degree in Q&A button lower
left I would now like to introduce
today's speakers dr. Daniel D sham dr.
Nikolas radio and Michael Dirr dr. Dan
Vikram is a senior staff scientist in
the discovery of biology group at the
molecular probes campus of thermo Fisher
Scientific in Eugene Oregon so he
developed cell based imaging
high-throughput screening in biochemical
tools for drug discovery invasive
Sciences research dr. Nicholas radio is
a manager cellular imaging and analysis
for Thermo Fisher Scientific in
Pittsburg Pennsylvania
he specializes in high content analysis
with expertise in drug discovery and in
Victor toxicity with emphasis and
development of an inveterate cardiac
neuronal and hepatic toxicological asses
Michael dirt earned his master's of
science from Oregon Health and Science
University Michaels research is focused
on development and commercialization of
next-generation closure systems for
pluripotent stem cell
differentiation in neuronal cell culture
a thermo Fisher Scientific on the cell
biology team based in Frederick Maryland
I will now turn over to hunter tuck
product manager of thermo Fisher hi
thank you yes this is hunter tuck I'm
the product manager for our neurobiology
portfolio of products here at thermo
Fisher and we're very excited to have
the second webinar today focused on the
tools and techniques to advance your
neurobiology research this is a second
in a series of webinars that we'll be
offering throughout the year focused on
solutions and neurobiology research if
you haven't already I would definitely
recommend checking out the first one
that we recorded back in May titled
improved differentiation of stem cell
derived neurons and downstream
applications through the reduction of
progenitor proliferation with culture
one supplement which was presented by
our own dr. David commander of R&D and
our cell biology business that webinar
specifically featured a new product
called culture one supplement that we
debuted last November and for more
information on that product please visit
our website thermo Fisher comm slash
culture 1 or simply Google culture 1 on
that site you can learn all about the
new innovative products that will
helpfully hopefully help you improve
your downstream research some of the
techniques of which we will talk about
today and you can also check out our
neurobiology protocol Handbook which
features all of our solutions across the
neurobiology research workflow so
without further ado I'll turn it over to
our first speaker dr. Dave dr. Dan
Beecham it was a senior staff scientist
and the discovery biology group thank
you and take it away day
great thanks so much hunter and thanks
so much for everyone who's tuned in to
listen to our broadcast today I'm going
to get to talk about an extension of the
work that hunter mentioned with the
Gecko team from the webinar that went up
in May a collaboration with with David
Cone injure and his team out there in
frederick maryland working on new new
media formulations to enhance and and
speed that the differentiation of neural
stem cells for functional assays and so
the functional assays are really we're
going to take the deep dive to in this
part of the talk so here I'll just give
a very brief overview of the content
we'll be looking at a couple of slides
looking at why we use fluorescent labels
in this kind of functional assay and
I'll go into the meat of the talk
describing how we used calcium
indicators and Anna cell proliferation
assay to monitor the progress of this
cell differentiation in culture one
medium and then I'll introduce a couple
of additional assays that we've
developed or developed further for also
for interrogating excitable cells of
course here at the probes campus we
still are very much focused on
fluorescent methodologies and so of
course what we're going to be looking at
in our graphical and and and in tabular
format are signals from cells that we're
going to record as an output of their
activity so in the case of neural cells
we're going to be very interested in
activity linked to action potentials and
and our indicator here is going to be
around calcium we use fluorescence of
course to enhance the contrast of an
otherwise relatively low information
content and otherwise invisible signal
on the left you can see some cardiac
myocytes and a still image just kind of
sitting there and on the right what you
can see are these cells when they're
loaded with a calcium indicator dye and
and on in the bottom left with on behind
the arrow you can see the calcium
oscillations placed from from the cells
from a
signal from a from a reference in a
region of interest over one of them that
shows the the the flux of calcium in and
out of the cells during their rhythmic
contractual beating so that's of course
an example for cardiomyocytes we're
going to use the same methodology to
interrogate the activity now of neuro
stem cell derived excitable cells in a
second part of the talk so jumping right
into it as Hunter hunter mentioned
you've got an introduction to the
culture one media product and its use
from David Cone injure back in May and I
just kind of wanted to highlight again
what the aims of the study that we're
going to look at will be like I wanted
our intention in this collaboration was
to prove some of the hypotheses we put
out there and in looking at the cells
after they were differentiated so this
product really is intended to cut down
on the number of contaminating non
differentiated cells that run amok in
traditional NSC cultures and can can
greatly blunt the responses in the
downstream assays like these functional
readouts I don't have any content to
share this time on its effect in primary
neurons as shown below there but watch
this space for for some exciting new
data as we develop further this space so
I just wanted to state the problem with
these cultures you know typically they
run some three weeks to get to at the
endpoint that where we want to sort of
ask the questions of the cells you know
either from a patient derived sample or
from a progenitor cell line about their
activity and these what's what's meant
to show what's shown in red here are
some of the problems that that we're
seeing in this field as it grows the
first and foremost being that they're no
longer a pure population of neurons or
rather of a cells period they're they're
a mixed population of progenitor cells
and cells that are either in different
states of division
or have not yet committed to to a
differentiation pathway so this this is
meant to show what what the issue is
some staining in the lower right showing
this this mixture of progenitor cells as
indicated by the Red Sox one staining
and then differentiated neurons by by
map to staining next slide shows a
little bit more closely and then more
importantly what what the effect of
culture one is we see a dramatic
reduction in the Sox positive cells and
then further enhancement of the map to
neural cell marker and then across the
top you can see again the sort of the
one of the issues that we encounter in
culturing cells in the absence of
culture one for these two and three week
time periods that are required to get
cells to a desirable endpoint so the
study that I'm going to outline for you
today is again designed to interrogate
the cells at several time points for
functional activity so the design of the
experiment here is to plate the cells
just very simply with and without the
the reagent culture one at a fixed
density and then each week I'm going to
do two tests one test of the the
excitability and sort of I'm going to
index the excitability by the cells
response to potassium depolarization of
some more detail on that and I also want
to look at the cell numbers that are in
each well to to ask you know what the
status of the proliferation is and
relative numbers of cells and more
importantly something that I can index
the calcium responses to I'm doing this
on two platforms our own thermo Fisher
various can flash plate reader just for
the endpoints i quant direct cell
proliferation assays and then the hama
Matsu FD SS 6000 high throughput plate
reader which is a kinetic imaging plate
reader with fluidics capabilities that
I'll go into a bit more and again these
two questions will be asking ourselves
still dividing and are they excitable
this slide is a sort of a close-up of a
snapshot of some HTS data some
high-throughput screening data as
you would see it on the screen these are
actually averages of four wells over
many time points and what you can see at
the base of that of that curve is is
where the injection this of the stimulus
is if I inject a control solution with
no additional potassium chloride I get a
sort of a little bump a stimulus
artifact we'd call that but if we add 30
milli molar potassium to the cells this
depolarizes the membranes and recruits
the activity of voltage-gated calcium
channels we know that voltage-gated
calcium channels are an important
hallmark of neuronal they're one of the
more important proteins related to
neuronal function that gate transmitter
release and a number of other signaling
and an action potential propagation
properties of differentiated neural
cells and they're largely absent from
the progenitor cells that will be that
we starting with here so this is
intended to show that the kind of data
that will be what that will be getting
and in the pictures on the Left just are
some microscopy images that I've taken
to show you again this is what you would
see in the microscope and then on the
right is what what the what the
photomultiplier sees in the high
throughput instrument so now we're going
to take a closer look at this data so
that we don't have to look at curves and
images anymore I just want to show you
nice bar graphs so we can highlight the
reproducibility of the study as well as
get a closer look at the comparative
amounts of signal so all I've done then
the manipulation of this data is to
export the the peak and then the time
period of two seconds on either side of
it from from each well and then place
place those into a spreadsheet and
average them with the other three
samples that were oh sorry in this case
I did a 12-person 'pl and it's averaged
them against each other to give the size
of the of the response in the various
conditions I'll point out the y-axis
here this is a measurement in
high-throughput called Delta F over F
that's fold increase in signal so really
that's just a running average of the the
starting signal
1.0 and then following the stimulus what
the relative change is in time as the
signal signal progresses so the first
bit of data that we got here will be
looking at data from data week 1 week 2
and week 3 so here we are in day 7 and I
set this up so that I could look at a
few things I should I was showing you
maximum responses to a 30 milli molar
potassium chloride stimulus here I've
shown a bit more detail I actually
stimulated the cells with control over
there with zero potassium and then
increasing doses of 5 10 or 5 15 20 and
30 milli molar to kind of ask number one
what is the maximum response possible
but do we see responses from the cells
at the lower doses as well and we'll
largely just pay attention to the
maximum but you'll be able to look at
these lower dose signals as well
throughout the study as I mentioned part
two the study is to look at the the cell
numbers so after one week just looking
in a white light microscope on an EVO
just as I think it's our one of our cell
culture microscopes I can see already
differences in just a morphology of the
cells and also in the again the cell
numbers as the the cells in the absence
of culture 1 medium are proliferating
and kind of encroaching in the middle of
the field and the cell numbers in
culture 1 have stayed the same but are
elaborating long processes so the assay
that I'm going to use to ask interrogate
the phone number is a simple one when we
like a lot because it doesn't rely on
the presence of ATP inside of the cell
is not sensitive to to contact
inhibition and and importantly these are
cells with long membranes and lots of
membranes and long processes so what we
do with this this means of following
proliferation is count the number of
nuclei it's very simple we have a very
bright green nuclear stain that we apply
to the cells in the presence of a an
extracellular quencher
cells that are compromised that have
been either killed by a drug or are just
simply not there will will the signal
from the nucleus will be quenched
because the dye can enter these these
damaged cells and then living cells are
left behind so this is a life positive
signal that that reliably records the
number of living cells in a culture
that's illustrated in a cartoon and
already what we see on day seven is that
there are about six-fold more cells in
the absence of culture one media than
there were in the in the presence and so
some numbers have stayed the same
relative to the day zero data and in the
presence of culture one the next few
slides are just going to now review day
days 14 and in days 21 so here we are on
day 14 now we're starting to see that
the real problem with with the with
growing cells in these conditions they
are stacking on top of each other and uh
and and you know just over growing the
plate and then the cells in the presence
of culture one again no change in the
density but a much much more in the way
of processes that we saw in the staining
for earlier that are going to be
positive for for map to and now so here
summarized on this slide is that the
culture one quantitative data sorry the
excite point and n flow for quantitative
data looking at the cell numbers and the
relative responses of the cells on day
14 so despite the fact that there are
twenty fold more cells in the control
condition we have smaller responses in
in in the flow for assay and and
skipping on now to day 21 cells again
showing clumping and this rather sort of
a difficult to image phenotype we can
now look look at this at the cells again
with these two assays and now we're
really seeing a
you know a big uptick in the India in
the culture one derive sells so without
any you know a need for for
normalization what we're seeing is that
is that there's a you know about twice
the signal coming from one twentieth of
the cells in the calcium a say in that
that speaks quite strongly of a greatly
increased expression of calcium on those
cells calcium channels on those cells
and and the responsibility to the
depolarizing stimulus this last slide
summarizes all of this data together
from day four day seven day fourteen and
twenty-one again highlighting the the
endpoint of the of the study in
particular the the day twenty one
difference between the cells with with
and without culture one in response to
30 milli molar stimulus so now in the
end of my talk here I will go ahead and
introduce a couple of other assays that
you can probably expect to see from us
in this place we would like to start
interrogating these cells with other
readouts
besides calcium to to ask a little bit
more deeply into asking what other
channels that they might be expressing
and also just introduce these assays as
important tools for any any neuro or
coronal ion channel type research that
that may be going on in your laboratory
so the two assays I'll introduce here
are one a potassium ion channel assay
called flux or and we've recently
re-released this as a greatly improved
and a larger signal-to-noise assay we've
also released a read form for working
with GFP and then also a very fast and
an high fidelity membrane potential dye
called flow volt which is used to record
action potentials and and other fast
events at the membrane and an imaging
mode I'll introduce the problem here by
stating you know the way you typically
traditionally measure channels over
there on the far left by convention
patch-clamp if you know one cell at a
time and an hours in a day and it takes
weeks to get you know good end numbers
and dose responses and so forth the
advent of automated patch-clamp has
ameliorated this somewhat it is
extremely expensive but it affords some
throughput to otherwise very difficult
or intractable targets and then on the
far right that number of targets
diminishes even further but but you know
has much higher throughput in the HTS
high throughput space where we can use
fluorescent kinetic assays to report the
activity of cells so I what I want to
show is in his first panel of assays
under under the flux or category here
we've opened up a whole new arm of the
channel the the ion channel compendium
of genes expressed by mammalian cells by
by introducing the flux or assay and
opened this now to to a high troop to
the high throughput space we did this by
using an approach with a surrogate ion
potassium is actually very difficult to
measure directly and in fact the
potassium changes inside of a cell are
very small so even if you could measure
them it'd be very hard to index the the
changes in potassium to the number of
channels that were open so what we did
instead is develop a dye that would
report the activity of phalerum inside
of cells valium selectively enters open
potassium channels and in fact passes
through is transported through potassium
selective transporters and then that
gives us a bystander kind of an ion that
that shows the relative number of open
channels in any given cell population by
the addition of thallium so it's very
easy to make valium sensitive dye that
will do this here with our chemists and
so we developed this this assay really
to to interrogate the activity of
potassium ion channels and transporters
and even the activity of g-protein
coupled receptors that coupled to them
as shown
right our first generation of this assay
was launched in 2009 and some years
later a competitor si appeared you can
see there in the middle set of set of
graphs in the top left that had a
slightly higher signal-to-noise and so
we we went back to the bench and
produced an even further improved signal
here with with it with a die that's a
much more sensitive and also gave us the
luxury of producing an assay that
retains all the pharmacological fidelity
you see in the lower right against a
common drug that efore o31 used against
the herd cardiac potassium channel but
also gives us the the opportunity to do
the SA and no wash this next slide just
simply shows another target the mixture
of ion channels that the kV 7.27 point 3
ion channels interrogated with either an
antagonist a partial antagonist that
inhibits the current and knocks the
signal down or an agonist that opens the
channels and causes an increase in the
signal so this assay isn't just for
looking at blockers this slide shows
that the new flux or to assay can be
configured it's a very very flexible and
can be configured in one of three ways
either the traditional to wash assay
where the dye is added and removed and
then you can replace with assay buffer
and have conditions very controlled you
can also do the assay in the absence of
media simply by removing the media and
replacing with with dye containing
buffer that's very dim at basal rest so
basal signal that doesn't doesn't
interfere or you can do this in a more
desirable and high throughput manner
where you simply add the dye as a 2x
formulation to the cells do the out say
in complete media and get the data and
you can see in the bottom there that the
removing those wash steps increases the
the Z prime because there are fewer
fewer steps that you have to manipulate
the cells a companion to this new tool
is that the flux or red assing really
should be called the flux or orange sa
this is the trick see
I exciting at 5:50 but we develop this
to to address questions from researchers
largely in this space working with
neural stem cells where GFP is often on
board as an indicator so the presence of
GFP can also be a confounding factor and
the need for for discovery screens in
outside of the green spectrum has been a
known demand to us for some time we also
wanted to make sure that that
researchers could do compound library
screens as a secondary or orthogonal
with with a different dye to get around
what the possible auto fluorescence
issues in the libraries so just to
briefly summarize flux or the flux or
kits we have a new flux or dye flux or
two green with a greatly improved
signal-to-noise great flexibility in its
need for wash or not and then I'd say
our flux or red sa is very similar to
the first generation flux or green assay
it does require a wash step and it
contains it gets about the same
signal-to-noise as the original the next
slide is an introduction to a fast
membrane potential dye that we launched
that we've named flow volt and this is
shown in comparison with our one of our
frontline fast dyes diet and EPS and a
patch clamp experiment where we've
clamped the membrane potential and then
stepped it to a series of depolarizing
of depolarizing values and stepped it
back and recorded the fluorescence from
the cells and what's that what that is
allowed us to do is load cells like in
this case a neural stem cell drive
sample and place a region of interest
over say a cell that you might be
interested in and monitor the voltage
excursions in real time with very fast
refresh rates and resolve action
potentials or clusters of action
potentials on these cells this this is
actually quite understand I think ten
millisecond intervals that we've we've
now got reports from researchers that
you can example in a sub millisecond
range
and actually record action potentials
from the base to the peak so membrane
allowing allowing the measurement of
membrane voltage as well as the flux of
particular ions like calcium or
potassium I'll conclude here just with
with a note about the three things I
talked about so culture one media
supplement in our studies there do show
and enhanced not just staining as you'll
see from from dr. radio and my code era
and then the talks to come but also
enhanced function as shown by our
calcium assay and then some new
generation ion indicator assays that
we've developed in a high-throughput and
discovery space to to assist scientists
working with excitable cells so with
that I think we're taking questions at
the end so I'm going to turn it over to
dr. Nick radio who is manager of
cellular imaging and analysis and it's
going to introduce a different kind of
micro plate based assay in high content
screening great thank you so much Dan so
what I'm going to be talking about today
is the need for high content technology
to evaluate developmental neurotoxicity
this is a subject that's pretty near and
dear to my heart it's it's a way of
evaluating different developmental
disorders things like autism and ADHD
the back story is that the traditional
methods to evaluate developmental
neurotoxicity they they take a lot of
resources because there are animal based
and because of that it can take
literally years to get risk data that is
necessary for safety Testaments so it's
it's resource prohibitive to attempt to
use these traditional models given the
fact that there are literally thousands
of compounds that are out there they're
used that we don't have adequate safety
data on so the challenge becomes how do
we develop more efficient screening
assays to give us some safety data on
these compounds that are out there so
what we are going to be talking about is
moving
the developmental testing into a
cellular model and in vitro model and
that's based on the premise that normal
the development of the brain is depend
upon several critical cellular processes
so these include things like cellular
proliferation differentiation and two
mature neurons migration neural
outgrowth that I'll be focusing on here
today synaptogenesis nomination and
finally program cell death and again
it's based on the principle that
neuronal cell cultures in vitro are able
to recapitulate these processes that we
see in vivo so neuro outgrowth has
received a lot of attention in the dnt
space because it's one of the principal
characteristics of a neuron that is
differentiated this slide here shows two
different models on the left-hand side
those are primary cerebellar granule
cells that are exposed to serum to allow
them to differentiate and on the right
hand side these are cells called NS one
cells it's a pc-12 subclone and at the
top there you can see the cells
undifferentiated after exposure to nerve
growth factor you'll differentiate the
neurons and you can see the neurite
outgrowth as shown in the bottom right
so even in vitro it is difficult to
identify and detect the neuroid
outgrowth it typically would involve
trained technicians to sit down and
manually trace each individual neuron
which is a pretty time-consuming process
and it is prone to scientist to
scientist variability when they're doing
that type of manual methodology so with
this technology we're utilizing the high
content screening to conduct the
analysis and the timeline it's it's as
efficient as you're going to get the NS
1 cells they take about four days to
differentiate following exposure to the
nerve growth factor the immunostaining
of the cells that takes about three
hours
from fixation permanent incubation with
the primary and secondary antibodies and
then finally you're ready to run the
analysis in an automated fashion using
high-content technology and just to give
you an idea so to look at a 96-well
plate an entire 96-well plate with three
images acquired and in each of those
images we have about a hundred cells
interneurons that are analyzed if I take
96 Wells multiply that by the three
images 100 cell density and then eight
end points things like neuroid outgrowth
branching cell size we can generate two
hundred and thirty thousand data points
per plate and that's done automatically
within about ten minutes to give you an
idea if if we did this manually it would
take closer to a hundred hours to do the
same type of research so it's it's
significantly more efficient what I'm
going to go into now are the different
optimization work that we did to
maximize the sensitivity of the assay so
this is just some preliminary work what
you see here is this is a dose response
curve of the nerve growth factor
inducing agent it's in nanograms per
milliliter and you can see this is
looking at neuroid outgrowth total
length so anything greater than 10
nanograms we see a significant increase
in the maximal neurite outgrowth length
just to be safe we chose a saturating
concentration of 100 nanograms per
milliliter and that way we repeatedly
were able to show nice robust neuroid
outgrowth in the pc-12 cells some other
things just to show you so in addition
to the nerd outgrowth you can see
neurite counts of the number of neurons
coming off of the cell body the cell
body area so of the soma and then
finally the total branch points and you
can see within each of these other
measurements at
nanograms we were saturating the cells
to induce the differentiation into the
neurons okay and then finally I wanted
to just show as far as the time courses
and some different compounds that we did
look at for control purposes in the
upper left hand corner what we're
looking at here is with and without
nerve growth factor at that saturating
dose of 100 nanograms per milliliter so
what you can see is that at a period of
96 hours we see a significant increase
in total neurite length especially
relative to the untreated control so in
normal healthy cells we would expect to
see approximately 80 microns of total
right wing in the differentiated neurons
and the upper right hand quadrant so
this is showing DMSO vehicle effect DMSO
was the vehicle that all the compounds
that we evaluated were suspended in and
we wanted to know that does the DMSO
vehicle itself cause any effect and
actually it does you can see as we
increase the concentration of DMSO we do
see a dose-dependent
decrease and no total right length so
it'll be safe we chose a final
concentration of 0.1 percent which was
you know it used a non significant
change in total right leg and then last
thing is to ensure our biology was
working we wanted to identify a
pharmacological control that we could
use to show that the expected nerd out
growth inhibition was occurring as a way
to biologically test the conditions in
the plate so the compound that we
selected after evaluating a few is a
protein kinase II inhibitor called dis
indole non-id one or this one and what's
really nice about business or mal amide
is here in green this is total outgrowth
and we see a very nice concentration
dependent decrease in neuroid outgrowth
at concentrations that
no effect on viability indicating that
it was a specific effect to the neurite
outgrowth biology in comparison to a
more generalized effect so we use the
dis indle now my data concentration of
three micro mores to actually show that
we were inhibiting the right outgrowth
as expected with this control and then
finally we wanted to evaluate whether or
not we were seeing any plate layout
effects in other words where cells that
were seated on the exterior Wells on our
plate were they any different than
biologies occurring and interior Wells
so when I say interior walls I'm talking
about ROS B through G and columns 2
through 11 and you can see when we treat
the cells in the same conditions the
exterior Wells versus the interior
there's no difference in the neurite
output length so we felt comfortable in
using the entire plate for our 96-well
screen so a long-winded answer but this
was how we optimize this assay we took
2,000 of our NS 1 cells we incubated
them with them without 100 nanograms of
nerve growth factor per milliliter
within a 96-well format we allow the
cells to hours to adhere to the bottom
of the plate at which point they were
exposed to the compound of interest that
we wanted the safety data on we chose 96
hours as our time interval based upon
the maximum neuroid outgrowth and
control cells at which point we fixed in
staining the cells that took about 3
hours and then conducted the high
content analysis within the system in
parallel we also used a viability
assessment and that was more so that we
could interpret was this something
specific to the neuron was it a
neurotoxic effect or was it more of a
generalized cytotoxic effect so here I
just have a plate map and what you can
see here is in column 1 we have our
roll Wells just quickly so a1 b1 and c1
was without nerve growth factor that was
our untreated population that served as
our negative control d1 e1 and f1 was
plus ng F so those were the healthy
positive control cells where we would
expect to see maximum neuroid outgrowth
and then finally G 1 H 1 that was the
dis in dorm al-anon treated cells that
acted as our pharmacological control
over the map of the rest of the 96-well
plate was devoted to our dose response
curve we selected a relatively broad
concentration range so one animal all
the way up to 100 micro molar it was
done in a semi logarithmic increase and
we chose that broad concentration range
because for the majority of these
compounds that we were interested in we
didn't really know at what concentration
they would be effective thus the broad
concentration range all right so what I
wanted to share was some of the
different patterns of effects that we
observed and looking at these different
environmental compounds so
diphenhydramine that is a compound that
is classically thought to be without
toxicity for developmental neurotoxicity
it's the active ingredient in benadryl
so it's an antihistamine and what you
can see here is that concentrations from
one nanogram one nano more concentration
all the way to 100 micro more there was
no change and what you see on the graph
in green that is total in the right
length so we can see all the way up to
100 micro molar there is no change and
in red that's the viability so we're not
losing any cells we're also not seeing
any change to total neurite length at
any concentration tested conversely we
saw non selective effects like you see
here with cadmium which of course this
is a heavy metal and you can see
starting at concentrations of about 1
micro molar and up we see a
dose-dependent decrease where both the
viability decreases
as well as Bernard outgrowth and we
would interpret this as a non-selective
effect meaning at concentrations that
reduced neuroid outgrowth they also
caused a generalized cytotoxic effect
and then finally the compounds that were
of most interest are shown here on the
right these are compounds that inhibit
neurite outgrowth at concentrations
where we do not see any change in
cytotoxicity and here you can see at
concentrations very low in the nano
molar range we see this dose-dependent
decrease in trans retinoic acid trans
retinal Cassidy is the active ingredient
in accutane it's a known developmental
neuro toxicant so it was reassuring that
we were able to see this positive effect
and just to show that we can actually
take this and scale it for a higher
throughput this was evaluating 320
different compounds we evaluated them at
a single dose response and you can see
that it was it was able to detect
compounds that showed a significant
decrease in both children right length
as well as viability so the proof here
is that we can take this type of screen
and efficiently run it through so that
within a month we have dose response
data on the entire test set to give you
a comparison to do the same type of
assay and your traditional rodent model
would take 480 years which obviously is
time and resource prohibitive so finally
I wanted to move along and just quickly
discuss some secondary measurements that
are of interest the first thing that I
wanted to show is this is just a cell
model comparison where the the dotted
line here we're now looking at
cerebellar granule ourselves relative
ns1 cells and the reason why I wanted to
show this is that it does show
differences in sensitivities to
different model systems so CG sees these
are primary cerebellar granule or so
and a lot of scientists would say that
these are more faithfully recapitulating
than vivo system so here with methyl
mercury this is a known DMT and you can
see that both compounds are both cell
models rather show the inhibition but we
do see a higher sensitivity in the ns1
cells it's even more dressed to key with
trans retinoic acid so as shown before
ns1 cells we see this significant
increase decrease rather in the neuro
doubt growth and then s1 cells with the
cg C's across all concentrations we
hardly see any change and then finally
just to show that we actually saw
increases in sensitivity with some of
the compounds with the primaries this is
showing lead to led of course this is a
known developmental neurotoxic in and
only the cerebellar granular cells at
the higher concentration showed a
decrease so what this showed us was that
to increase the sensitivity to the
screen it's really valuable to use
multiple models to cast as broad of a
net as possible one of the advantages of
using high content is because the
technology is automated it gives the
ability to look at multiple time points
simultaneously and what I wanted to
share here briefly this is showing a new
endpoint so total branch points in blue
in addition to the net length and
viability that we looked at previously
and I wanted to share this because so
these compounds are pyrethroids decides
pyrethroids are used very regularly
within agriculture
and there's some concern about their
their safety so bifenthrin when we look
at bifenthrin at all dose responses it's
not until we get to the higher
concentrations that we see a decrease in
both total net length as well as
branching however for other compounds
like cypermethrin another one of these
pesticides notice that only branching
a change nirodh outputs and viability
are relatively unchanged at all
concentrations tested and what that
shows us is that if we evaluate other
end points such as branching we're able
to increase the sensitivity of our assay
so that we're not missing any compounds
that may be causing toxicity and then
last thing as I wrap up here this is
showing synaptogenesis and
synaptogenesis is an assay that can only
be done in primary cells what I want to
show just an interest of time is here we
see synaptogenesis assay so channel 1
nucleus channel 2 the beta 3 tubulin
where we see the neurite outgrowth
channel 3 in red the synapse formation
and if we look at this a high content no
technology is great for this type of
evaluation where we can validate only
the neurons we can exclude the glia like
we see here based upon size and shape we
can take the resulting neuron morphology
and along the neurites
so here we see the tracing of the
neurons that are being detected that
becomes our region of interest and along
that region of interest we can identify
the synapse formation and what was
really interesting to us is that that
synapse formation that we were looking
at using high content technology matched
methodologies that are much more
resource and time required to conduct
the assay so in a much more efficient
screening assay such as high content we
can show that level of synaptogenesis as
we had showed here and with that in the
interest of time I'll go ahead and wrap
it up and pass it on to my colleague
Michael Dirr who is a scientist within
cell biology
Thank You Nick so the title of my talk
is neuronal applications of high content
analysis and I'm going to go going to
show some examples of assays that we
have developed and frequently used
throughout the media development process
and hopefully provide some insight into
the absolute development process so just
an overview as the examples out over so
there's a cell population
characterization I guess more
specifically neuron counting and then
multi parametric high content analysis
of neuronal maturation and then finally
glial cell quantitation in primary
neurons and just kind of before I get
into the examples I'm going to give a
brief description of what high content
analysis is so it's the basically
automated image capture coupled with
automated image analysis software and
the software allows connotation of
basically hundreds of parameters within
a single field and the instrument that
we are using is the cell size cx5 and
that is coupled with the hgf studio
image analysis software so kind of
getting into the the athlete develop
development process a little bit I like
to show this image as an example of a
culture that's not really ideally suited
for high content analysis you can see
it's it's a highly mixed population of
really densely packed cells and the
cells are kind of on top of each other
and forming mounds and kind of clumping
and these are these are culture
characteristics that make it very
difficult for the software to reliably
identify objects and
make accurate measurements on the images
so so part of the the athlete
development process involves trying to
make the biology facilitate kind of the
technology in in a sense so this is kind
of an extreme example in this image but
some ways of doing this involved
adjusting seating densities or
experiment endpoint times or trying
different reagents if possible so along
these lines antibody selection is very
important localization or antibody each
specificity and high signal-to-noise
ratios are definitely things to consider
and yeah as I previously described the
spatial distribution of the cells is
also very important okay so now I'm
going to get into the first example I'm
going to show an example of neuron
counting and this kind of illustrates
why antibody selection is important here
we have day 21 primary rat cortical
neurons that are staying with it's too
different in your own specific
antibodies and the map too is on the
left and then you see B in the middle
and you can see that the map 2 has kind
of a diffuse staining pattern it stains
both the neurites and the cell bodies
while the hew CD antibody is localized
cell bodies only and in the third image
you can see that both of these
antibodies are singing the same cells
they're both neuron specific so it's
important to kind of make sure that your
antibody is has the correct specificity
and so now I'm going to kind of show why
the cell body staining antibodies
simplify the neuron counting process
and this is another this is a good
example of how the biology can
facilitate the software so by using the
cell body localized antibody we can use
a very simple image analysis essay
called the target activation assay and
so yeah this is a very simple assay that
is also very versatile we actually use
this in many many different applications
but so just kinda to show how this assay
works first you use the Dappy stained
nuclei here seen in blue on the left and
the software identifies objects in the
dabby channel and if you can hopefully
can see the the yellow mask that's
generated there and so then the software
kind of duplicates the dapping mask for
the UCD channel and measures the
intensity for each of the identified
objects so the low intensity objects are
your non neuronal population and are not
counted and they're actually in red now
in the right image the low intensity
wants and then the the high intensity
objects are the gcd positive neuronal
population and they're still kind of in
yellow sorry about the colors aren't
ideal in this image but so so that the
output from this assay can be the number
of neurons or the % neurons and again
cell body or even nuclear localized
antibodies really allow for simplified
their own counting and this is just a
deep data representation of why the UC d
antibody is good for counting we see the
cell intensity population distribution
Illustrated as a histogram here and so
for this the the target activation assay
was run using either the map 2 antibody
and or the the UC d antibody
and on the bottom panel the UCD object
intensity distribution shows a very
clear kind of resolution between the
neuronal population which is highlighted
in green and the non neuronal population
which is highlighted in red so on the
x-axis is intensity so the higher
intensity population is on the left and
then closer to zero you have the the
non-neuronal low intensity population
and so comparing that to the map to
histogram on the top on you can see that
that histogram there's a lot of overlap
of the positive and negative population
so again GCD enables clear resolution of
the neuron the neuronal and the non
normal population
and here I'm just showing that the gcd
antibody can also be used for to
quantify IPSC derived and differentiated
neurons whenever you're using antibodies
for a system to identify a specific cell
type you definitely want to make sure
that they are singing the correct cell
so here's the shows that the GCD in the
map 2 is our staining the both staining
the same cells in these IPS D Drive
nouns ok so now moving on from the
neuron connotation we're going to look
at an example of quantitative analysis
of neuronal maturation and this is a
great example of how like the improved
culture characteristics can facilitate
the software enable accurate
quantitation so this is a
differentiation time course for IPSC
drives and it's the differentiation to
neurons with culture one
and so at day zero this experiment NFC's
were plated in differentiation media
with culture one and the cells were
fixed at day to day four day seven and
day fourteen and then they were stained
with the map to antibody and so early on
a day 2 and day 4 you can already see
nice neuronal growth and as time goes on
the cells continue to mature forming
these really nice complex there right
networks you can see in day seven and
certainly at day 14 and also the cells
are really nicely spatially distributed
and there are virtually no progenitor
cells present on the bottom panel shows
the software generated object
identification mask for each
corresponding image and the cell bodies
are seen in kind of the turquoise color
and the neurites are in purple and you
can see that the the neurites are being
accurately identified if you compare the
images so basically because culture one
eliminates the clumping in the
progenitor cell proliferation it really
simplifies the object identification
process and improves the accuracy and it
really decreases the assay development
time because you're not having to really
train the software very much to identify
the objects and here is the the data
output from the time course experiment
on this is the multi parametric analysis
of neuronal maturation and for this i
there's six different parameters that i
measured and all of these are kind of
metrics of maturation so on the top left
you have the neuron counts or the QCD
positive cells
and you can see as time goes on from day
2 to day 14 your your neuronal account
is increasing and then below that one
you have the NSC count which is just
really around 2 to 3 cells per field
it's very low and it does not increase
over time suggesting that you know
you've gotten rid of the proliferation
of the progenitors and then the right
four graphs are have to do with neurite
quantization quantization different kind
of aspects as new right so you have no
right length in the right area on the
top and those are increasing over time
and then you have no right branch points
and in the right widths so all of these
with increasing normal mentation you get
you know increased complexity of your
new right network and these are all
measured here so it's a nice way to kind
of monitor maturation over time so right
again the enhanced maturation of culture
one really facilitates a reliable and
data rich analysis of your
differentiated neurons and these are
this is a very similar as I set up to
the the drug screening or the toxicity
assay that Nick was speaking to earlier
and it also is very similar to how you
know drug screens are are done okay now
so shifting gears I'm going to the third
example of astrocyte quantitation so
this is actually a slide from David Cone
inter stock that was mentioned earlier
and these are day 21 Mouse cortical
neurons and we found kind of developed a
new application for culture one that
allows you to suppress your glial cell
population and also control your glial
cell population so on the top you have
right day 21 Mouse coracle neurons with
no cultural and treatment and on the
bottom you have culture one treatment
starting at a zero day three and a seven
and then these cultures were then
culture per day for 21 days and it we
show that if you start a cultural and
treatment at day zero you get a complete
suppression of your astrocytes and then
if you delay the treatment into day
three and day seven you get increasing
amounts of astrocytes so you can really
control the levels of your astrocytes
and so how we did this quantitation is
demonstrated here so your astrocytes
generally kind of grow in little
together in little areas so it's
important to do a large number of fields
so here's a montage of sixteen fields
and on the right is the object
identification mass generated by the
software and the readout for this is
total object intensity per well and
object area per well and here's just the
same same slide from before but I
substituted in the sixteen field montage
images so you could get a better
understanding of what's going on over
the entire surface of the well and here
is it's kind of the same story for the
oligodendrocytes if you start cultural
and treatment at day zero you can get
complete suppression of your
oligodendrocytes and then delay the
treatment you get increasing amounts and
again getting short on time but this is
just how we are identifying these the
masses on the right so to wrap up the
conclusions here high content analysis
is a highly versatile tool for analysis
of neuronal cultures initial athlete
development considerations antibody
selection in culture characteristics can
dramatically improve accuracy and
simplify quantitation and then a
cultural and supplement and enhance
the maturation of enna sees yielding
ideal culture characteristics for high
content analysis and cultural and
supplement can be used to suppress and
control the levels of glial cells and
primary neurons so that's it and thank
you for listening
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question-and-answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can
our first question is for dr. Boojum can
you add cultural and supplement to cells
at different times during the culture
what is the outcome yeah you sure can
basically the data that I showed was
with culture one added on day zero and
then we followed the trajectory of the
differentiation over three weeks adding
at different time points will allow the
progenitor cells to proliferate more so
you can kind of control or titrate the
cell numbers by by when you add it I'll
point out though that it doesn't act
like an ad a mitotic it again basically
arrests division and steers cells toward
a differentiated phenotype more quickly
so and also some of Michael's data also
hinted at this showing different time
points that you can add it to primary
neuronal cultures I hope that answers
your question
thank you dr. Deaton this next question
is also for you can level guys we use in
microplate acids or is it used limited
to high frame rate microscopy and
imaging yeah flow volt membrane
potential dye is a fast membrane
potential indicator dye that is best
used in microscopy you need very high
frame rates to measure action potentials
but it's been used to do so that said
I've seen now a couple of papers in the
cardiac safety space where researchers
have monitored membrane voltage with
flow volt in a micro plate format while
while pacing cells are monitoring
spontaneous beating and looked at
changes in interest bike interval with
with drugs of interest cardiac myocytes
have a much slower sort of kinetics than
the neurons do and
oh can you know relatively slow frame
rates can resolve it but by and large
its uses in high frame rate acquisition
microscopy our next question is for dr.
radio what range of Z values are typical
for HCM morphology measurement typically
you see between point three and point
four Z prime values and that's that is
relative to the complexity of just
aneroid outgrowth biology that occurs in
themselves there have been some assays
more recently an actually pretty
complicated model primary hippocampal
model where they published is Z prime
value of a point seven three that was
other vance lemons lab at the University
of Miami I would say that's a extremely
good Z prime value given the complexity
of the assay but as far as a range
anywhere from point 3 to point 7 is what
what has been noted in the field
thank you our next question is for
Michael Dirr can culture 1 be used to
suppress glial cells in a mouse
hippocampal neuron
it sounds like Michael might have some
trouble tuning in and if we don't get an
answer here in a second I can speak to
that okay well yes the short answer is
yes it can be used on primary neural
cultures where again as data indicated
it will suppress the proliferation of
glial and an immature immature cell
types or dividing cell types so I showed
a bunch of data with culture one in the
context of neuro stem cell derived
cultures and and then Michael followed
with a fair bit of data also looking at
primary cultures where glial and other
dividing cells can contaminate and
overrun the culture and so yes it will
suppress glial proliferation and in
primary cultures thank you the next
question is for dr. radio what other
endpoints aside from your art acura can
be informative for HCA screen yeah
that's a good question so in addition to
the nerd outgrowth other measurements
that are going to be valuable are
branching like we showed in the
presentation there with the pesticide
model that's a good secondary endpoint
that has different targets than what we
see for neuroid
outgrowth formation and as a consequence
it can show different sensitivities to
toxic an exposure more recently people
are turning to things like pre and post
synaptic cuncta to evaluate
neurotransmission and both of those
things are known could be critical for
the development of the healthy nervous
system so I'd say those are good targets
as well the next question is also for
dr. radio um
on slide 45 test site or toxicity was
measured over time or was it measured at
only one time point how does it how does
it change over time it's a great
question yeah so when we were initially
setting up the assay we did it as a time
course where we looked at multiple time
points we ended up selecting 96 hours
for our screen which is the data that I
showed and that was just because of the
screen and the number of compounds and
the number of concentrations we did that
at one fixed time point but leading up
to it for the optimization work it was
looked at across hours as well as days I
hope that answers your question
thank you
the next question is for dr. radio can
the readers be combined with pros for
mitochondrial function in HCA platt one
given that mitochondrial function in
health is considered important for your
right a scrub or C not so Genesis again
that's another really good question by
the audience so yeah you can evaluate it
what we would do is a multiplex it in a
different Channel outside of the nerd
outgrowth measurements that we were
looking in it and what you can do is you
can do something like a ma'idah tracker
and that would allow us to look at the
mitochondrial number you could look at
the morphology of the mitochondria and
based upon the intensity of the dye you
can get a sense for the membrane
polarity and all of those things can be
simultaneously measured using the
neuronal profiling publication that's
available on our high content technology
the next question is also for dr. Reiter
what is the biggest challenge
encountered by researchers been using
HCA's for neurobiology applications and
do you have any suggestions for
overcoming this
I think the biggest challenge remains
the extrapolation step when we talk
about simple neuronal cell lines like
the pc-12 and s1 cells and my
presentation there's a lot of concern
about how well those more simple cell
models extrapolate into in vivo
conditions it's much more challenging to
work with primary cells just from you
know the need to have an animal facility
potentially the additional culture work
in some primary models they don't like
antibiotics so contamination is more
easy and because of those complexities
it's more difficult for researchers to
do you know I think it's why some of the
topics that we're talking about with the
media as well as some of the new
technologies that are available on the
imaging side such as integrated
comprable are really important so that
the scientists can be enabled to look at
those more complex biologies and more
complicated cell models thank you okay
it looks like we have time for one last
question
our next question is for dr. degen
neural activity indicating guys have
typically have have typically had issues
of toxicity how do disposal and
potassium indicators fare sorry I didn't
quite catch the the caveat there so
indicator dyes have a problem with what
could you repeat Malik yes your own
electricity neuronal activity indicating
guys have typically had issues of
toxicity how do the flow volt and
potassium indicators there sorry I'm
interpreting this question is are these
are these dyes toxic short answer is no
not in the time course of their utility
flow volt dye acts just like a flow for
or other calcium indicator dye sits low
dated the cells as a
flex or die rather is loaded into cells
as an a.m. Esther where it resides for
something on the time course of an hour
to 90 minutes but can certainly stay a
good deal longer in the context of a
high-throughput screen cells respond
with the same fidelity at one hour and
four hours and eight hours after loading
flow volt as well I'll point out loading
with this die is is sort of cell
type-specific typically loading is very
short with with slow volt membrane die
you apply it for fifteen to thirty
minutes and then remove it overloading
the dye will blunt the response but is
not toxic to the cells I hope that
answers the question I'm not sure if I
quite caught what the real question was
I would like to once again thank dr.
Daniel Beecham dr. necklace radio and
Michael chair for their presentation I
would also like to thank our sponsors
thermo Fisher Scientific gibdo for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
January 2018 you will receive an email
from labyrinth alert alert receptacle to
be available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
lab set see you next time and good bye